i had on the subject of our podcast
kind of a fun experience which is a
couple days ago
i went uh and and visited my in-laws
uh up on bainbridge island
um in uh in seattle so i went to seattle
and then you get on a ferry and you go
over to bainbridge island
and there was a gathering there and i
attended with my wife and kids we had a
lovely time and then you drive back the
other direction and you get back on the
ferry to go back to seattle
and
we're waiting in line and i get out to
kind of just stretch my legs
and because we're waiting on the ferry
and sitting in our car our cramped
rental car
nice dig
i'm sorry it was it was a little you
know what it was it's a perfectly i'm
not going to name the car it was a
perfectly fine car but i as you know i
have freakishly long legs
and not the most generous interior on
this car
it's very hard to rent a bugatti and um
and so
this was a uh an american car that was a
little cramped up front and so i get out
and i'm stretching my legs and
these people
uh in the car next to me recognize me
and they're very excited which is nice
and their windows are down and they go
this is so weird and i said what and
they said we listened to the podcast on
this commute
back and forth
to bainbridge island all the time
and here you are
and you know it's half leaning into
their car invading their space
because i'm a meaty person and i really
wanted to get my head all in their car
and be like
how are you and
um you nixon them i nixon again the old
nixon
that's nixon motorboating a woman
i couldn't i am no
not a crook
i could
i'm talking to them and it just was so
funny because
i i it just tickled my fancy that here
are people who they do this commute a
lot and can you imagine if your commute
every day and you you like this podcast
you're listening to it
and you it's you're part of your regular
diet and
the next thing you know i'm sticking my
head in your window like they summoned
you yes exactly it was like the
conjuring and so it got me thinking that
i should make it
i want to pledge to people out there who
listen to this on a commute
there's a decent
chance you will encounter me while
you're in your car and i will stick my
head in the window the more you listen
the more that is likely yes and
um it'll be kind of like you know when
you hear sometimes about someone who
hits a deer with their car and the deer
gets partially through the windshield
and the deer starts thrashing that's me
if i know you've been listening to the
podcast and i encounter you and i stick
my head in i may become wild and start
thrashing oh man yeah and then you've
got to just put me out of my misery as
quickly as possible do you ever get
upset that people mention the podcast
but don't mention that 28 years
on television you know what's so funny i
don't
really yeah you'd think i would um
i think if someone went way out of their
way to say i love this podcast what were
you doing before
that would
well it means they're keeping up with
you that's so good but i'm telling you i
am i you know uh it doesn't happen a lot
but there are still times when i
encounter someone and they go like oh my
god conan o'brien
you are i just love what you did on the
simpsons
and i'll say oh that's great and they
sometimes almost look like they don't
know what happened after that
and i so i'm happy if anyone likes
anything i did if someone says that that
uh crocheted potholder you made
for mrs gaines in the fifth grade was
just killer i'll take it
so i'm just happy that people like it
but um it did get me interested in oh
right people
listen
a lot of people listen to podcasts while
they're commuting yes and i just want
you to know if you're commuting right
now yeah or if you're in your car and
you're listening
um look in your back seat look in the
back seat and i'm there's a i want to
say there's an 11
chance i will rise up behind you you'll
see me in the rearview mirror god and
i'll give you the old nixon motorboat
come here pat come here
oh no
he's motorboating those guys too no he
wants them to watch he wants an erickman
to watch him motorboat pat this is what
was on the missing portion of the
watergate yeah yeah exactly that he
wasn't worried about being caught when
he was just decent
when they
suspected him of having his assistant
rosemary woods delete
the crucial 18 minutes
he wasn't it wasn't it wasn't him
worried about being caught orchestrating
the break-in or the cover-up of the
watergate it was the 18 minutes of him
motorboarding pat path
and more so because he had a method that
he didn't want to get out there you know
no one must know motorboating i have a
secret method with ladies to drive from
crazy
no one must know my motorboating about
the old five o'clock shadow grow out a
little bit no
a little friction now
you get the old peace signs in the air
oh the shadow
yeah it's just gonna hurt no just if you
grow it out just a little bit it's just
exfoliating yeah it's an exfoliant yeah
come here oh you lose your loofah come
here take off your top
please mr president if you don't have a
loofah take off your top i'm gonna give
you the breasts of a 20 year old yeah
i'm gonna loof you up real good
get rid of the old
dick nixon
a motorboat
no checkers don't go in there